[Applause]
welcome
live from new york okay it's not live
but i am so pleased to be
in new york uh last year as you know
the first of you who watched the first
down down the middle with jeffrey
gundlach was live
filmed in los angeles that was my first
post covet trip
this is my second and it's so important
to me to be here today with phillip
howard
because i'm crossing the boundary from
my comfortable spot from monetary policy
from being the fed whisperer
to economics and finance to policy
because i think we're finally at a
crossroads in america
where the two must meet in order to make
forward progress
so i'm so pleased today to bring to you
phillip howard chair of common good
thank you for being with me
great to be with you danielle um i'm
going to start this off with my
favorite favorite favorite writer in the
world
she won a pulitzer in 2017.
noonan and this was
when the world was realizing that donald
trump was going to be the nominee
for the republican party and she made
some observations then
that were so powerful because they were
so clean
and she wrote the protected make
public policy the unprotected live
in it you know that democrats won't
protect you
and republicans won't help you
your thoughts well i think washington
has taken a life of its own it's always
been the case but it's worse than
the bigger government gets i mean
there's this
there's this enclosed world there
where um to the republicans everything's
self-referential about
you know their kind of theory of the
economy and theory of life
but it's not directly connected to the
real life problems of
you know sort of people on the ground
and the democrats have their theories
uh which are sort of extremists
and they also don't really
uh seem to think much about what
what real people need both both
economically but also
sort of emotionally to you know to have
ownership
of local services and not to have big
brother
tell them how to run their schools that
sort of thing sure so
so you do i think peggy's completely
right i mean you know you
you have these these two parties that
aren't
really connected to the real people
that they're supposed to be governing
but
if i remember from growing up in a very
conservative household
it wasn't always this way i mean when i
was growing up at least the democrats
were the party for the people
that was kind of what at least it was
what was
it was it was how they represented
themselves but it seemed like today
both parties are representatives
in some way for corporate america uh
yeah i think that's right i mean they're
they're the the washington is a mighty
engine of the status quo
so there are you know over 5 000 big
interest groups in washington 5 000 yeah
5 000
and and these interest groups all sorts
of fewer things they're the big ones
like aarp for senior citizens whatever
and they're all mainly devoted to the
status quo
and some of them um protect
some of them are democratic leaning like
the public unions
you know they're there for preserving
the entitlements
and the lack of accountability and lots
of other
destructive things in my view uh
for for public employees and some of
them
are supporting the conservatives and
the republicans big business groups but
none of them
are really focused on what
policy should be they're really um
you know they're they're agents you know
how when you're talking to a law i'm a
lawyer i confess
but but but when you're talking to a
lawyer uh he's representing his client
so he's thinking what does my client
want
he's not thinking about what the right
thing to do is all these interest groups
are not thinking about what the right
thing to do is the people at arp
are not thinking about the grandchildren
of the elderly and who's going to pay
the bill
when we when we overspend and give
benefits
you know when the average age has gone
from whatever it was in the 1930s when
social security was created to
you know 10 years longer right they're
not worried about
the grandchildren they're worried just
about keeping what the grandparents have
and it's so it's kind of a phony model
where these agents aren't
looking at the common good and the
effect
is the parties aren't looking at the
common good either
you know i saw an interesting chart
recently and it showed the evolution
of the age of
senators going back 50 years and it was
just a colorful chart
showing that as time has gone by the age
of the average senator has gone just
absolutely
through the roof in the past two three
decades
right right where you have this it's it
but that's a function i think to a great
extent of
of um the extension of lifespans
you know modern medicine and such and
the fact that
once you get into office
particularly for senators you tend to
stay in office
and it's like the rest of washington
it's all about the status quo
once you're there you're there and and
everybody's sitting there
defending the status quo and doing
pretty well doing it they're in this
endless kind of tug of war right where
nobody really moves too much
and they make money and support their
families and there's no real risk
involved
and so you have this you know it's
almost like
the beltway around washington is um
it's like a gear uh you know it's like
disconnected from the rest of the
country
so this washington spins round and round
and and the rest of the country is doing
whatever it does but
but not really connected to washington
so uh i i look at
one of my greatest inspirations will
always be abraham lincoln
of the people by the people for the
people
and in thinking about today's talk with
you
i was i was pondering
kind of the american dream and being
able to
be born into whatever circumstances
you're born into
and still live the dream
and i i said to myself there's three
major ceilings that exist today
that didn't exist when so many
successful people today who are at the
ends of their career
can look back and say i was born into
nothing and i became this
this icon and
if you look at working parents
especially
working mothers and
their inability to step
out of the workforce to have a child and
step right back in
because child care is so prohibitively
expensive and if you combine that with
unions in the fact that we could educate
our children
at a younger age and get rid of this
working mothers leaving the workforce
and coming back in
and then you layer on to that um
higher education right and higher
education
which has become its own ceiling
so there's three different things that
would hold back
somebody born into a lower station if
you will on a lower
income rung that didn't exist before and
it seems like there are such
simple answers to address these so that
you could reopen
that ladder right it's interesting uh
you know the the role of women in the
economy is
uh it has to be one of the most
important things along with maybe the i
you know the i.t revolution you know
that you know in the last
century because we could particularly
last half century and
and because it because of all the
reasons you take because of
child care complications because of
uh the need to work to keep the family
going the the
husband can't make enough money and many
jobs to
to you know make ends meet so you need
two working parents
and there hasn't been that much thought
about what the what the policies
should be and i i think you're right i
think
you know there is a need for um
schooling so rethinking of schooling
both the age at which people go to
school
i mean we could talk about the
underclass at some point
the school ought to start at birth you
know for the underclass
i mean the complete agreement yeah
that's how you keep a dynamic workforce
they never fall out of the workforce
they never fall into the safety net
right and and in the case of the
underclass the kids
need to have a chance and there's been
so many generations now
of single mothers that by the time the
kids get to be three or four is too late
they haven't heard enough words
and so everyone i know i just got
goosebumps
yes yeah yeah yeah in in that world
thinks that we need to have a
a kind of um
dramatic and massive intervention
social intervention into the lives
of these infants you know that
that that help them and their mothers
grow into the society
and then for larger society as you point
out
we need to have a different
but comparable intervention to
to permit women to actually participate
in the workforce
i i i mean these are just such a
critical and the idea uh i mean what
my twins were born as bear stearns was
melting
and i was i was i i never even left
but the workforce during that time i
remember i was
briefing richard fisher from
from the intensive care unit because the
financial system was melting down
and but i had the privilege i had the
ability to to have help with me
i was always able to work from home
because i was always connected
and what we're seeing in a post-covered
world
is it's not only
that they're that so many children in
america are disadvantaged
because they don't live in that one zip
code
but once we became virtual learning
the inequality divide just exploded open
yeah yes you're absolutely right and
and we need to rethink the role of
education the timing of education
uh we need to rethink summer vacation
we used to have summer vacation because
the kids needed to work on the farms
you know that's not true anymore so so
why do we have summer vacation
and if you look at some of the most
successful schools
they've begun to kind of dislodge those
old assumptions
to you know to to great benefit
for the children when do you think
children should begin inside the
public education system
um well i think for the underclass
the as i said i think there should be an
intervention
with children not coming in so much the
education system but in
a kind of a parody help system you know
like um
almost like pods of young mothers with
helpers
and their infants spending half the day
or more together
both with the mothers learning and the
children the infants
hearing and learning and they're they're
really wonderful programs that do that
in big cities around the country but
that costs money obviously
um for for for other kids i think the
sooner the better i mean kids love
they like to be social
we have grandchildren and they go off to
school
before the age of three you know when
they're off at uh
at nursery schools
or another that are very social and very
well organized and
and the children have the enormous
advantage of spending not all day but
in this case it's i think it starts out
at
a few hours a day and then the next year
it gets
it gets larger but but there's a reason
that the children
uh of parents who can afford to do that
do that
right and it seems to to work pretty
well so why shouldn't we do that for
for for everybody and on the other end
you know this whole idea of higher
education
needs to be rethought too i mean
you know we have these totemic ideas
about getting a college degree
and stuff you can do really well in life
if you are properly uh
socialized you know how to work with
people you show up at the right time you
you you understand what it means to take
responsibility and all that kind of
stuff
and then you add to that some skills
that fit your the skills of a mechanic
the skills of a plumber or whatever
those things are really valuable you
make a lot more money doing that than
you would as a phd
so so it's i can attest to that my hvac
guy
my air conditioning guy i know he's
driving a better nicer car than i am i
promise
yeah exactly so so we need to do what
other countries have done
and understand that
the college degree you know sitting in
an office with wearing a
in the old days wearing a tie is is
really not for everybody and it's not
all that a society needs and
and we ought to have multiple pathways
for people to
not only to learn skills
and to get into the workforce but also
to to feel self-respect
you know for doing that i mean doing a
good job at anything
is takes work and
and there there's there's pride in being
able to
fix a car you know or or fix the hvac
system and
and and america used to honor those
things
and now we have this kind of
i don't know kind of vague notion that
unless you
uh you know unless you have a white
collar job you haven't succeeded
and yet we can't um i mean one of the
things that's so frust
so many just listening to your answer
right now i had unions pop into my head
over and over again and it's not just
it's not just
unions in the public education system
but it's also
limitations in terms of apprenticeships
that certain unions uh
have so they put a governor on the
number of trades people
that we can train in this country at a
given time which is just
i i i don't know where unions
belong anymore anywhere in this country
and yet we've just introduced
legislation
to make unionizing easier again right
okay this is really it is really an
important issue
because i think there is a this is two
discussions
there are the private unions and before
they were private unions
um many employers didn't treat
employees well and we didn't have lots
of other then the regulatory system kind
of built up worker safety laws that sort
of thing
and did much of the job that private
unions
do but uh and the private unionization
has declined it's now
six percent of the private workforce
something like that it's fairly small
maybe half what it was 20 30 years ago
although my view is the presence of
private unions
or the potential threat of private
unions
does keep
big employers honest so for example
i've studied how the how the toyota
management system works in their
manufacturing plants and
for example in kentucky
they have a lot of protections so
before they fire somebody they have
these workers counsel that
that that talk about and review the file
of the person they're about to fight
and about fire and so the company thinks
it's in its interest
to make sure that all the workers
feel that they're going to be fairly
treated and so there's a safeguard you
can't just give
supervisors you can't just go fire and
i'm pretty
confident that those same safeguards
wouldn't exist
but for the threat of unions right you
know in other words so
so i think the presence of unions um
private unions where the potential
presence you know does
kind of keep things you know an even
keel for the companies that are not
unionized
well we did see amazon raise prices yeah
yeah i mean
raise wages excuse me at the threat of
exactly and so i think there's a so i
think there's a role there
public unions which is now the largest
unionized group
ought to be banned they are
in almost every respect and i don't
think this is too strong a word
evil they negotiate against the
interests of the public
in so many ways they've
basically bought off politicians so that
a political leader today
makes promises for pensions that come
due long after the term is up so that
you have states like illinois
that are actuarially insolvent insolvent
you know there are um i think something
like 20
000 pensioners public prisoners in
illinois that get over a hundred
thousand dollars in pension
that's two billion dollars a year of
taxpayers so you're talking about
and they're working and living in
florida by the way yeah and they got to
retire when they were 55.
right exactly so you have this
incredible so one
it's made certain states effectively
bankrupt
two uh you you can't fire anybody
literally you can't find two out of
three hundred thousand teachers
on average get terminated in california
which has one of the worst
say that one more time two out of three
hundred thousand
a year can get terminated you know
through the process
i guess you have to be filmed beating a
student yeah
exactly so you've got you there's this
great story in new york
there was this teacher who was caught
selling cocaine on school property
including to other teachers
who was indicted convicted sent to jail
came back demanded his job back and an
arbitration got his job back
a drug dealer yeah yeah yeah drug dealer
so so
so you have these so it's literally
so uh so there's no accountability
and the harm of no accountability is not
that
um there are all these terrible people
like the drug dealer although there are
some
um the harm is that when everybody knows
that job performance doesn't matter
it makes it almost impossible to
manage an energetic institution because
everybody knows it doesn't matter so
it's like letting air out of bloom
so you have these sluggish uh horrible
departments and schools
where where the people who try to
resuscitate them don't have a chance and
if you find the ones that are successful
and there are many like
the only centers for disease control is
a direct
you know over history been a really good
agency even though it kind of fumbled a
little bit with coven
um there are public schools that are
fantastic
but if you go to those schools those
schools are fantastic
because there's a trust that's either
instilled by leadership or by their
culture
that everybody's gonna work their ass
off to make it work oh yeah and
and it's a cultural trust and if you uh
but in most institutions if you know it
doesn't matter what you do
it's almost impossible to build that
trust and so you have these lousy
institutions because everybody knows you
won't be accountable if you go to your
job
and that's just a terrible thing so
that's another
thing that the public unions do there's
no accountability and then
the last one i'll mention although i've
written a lot about this
is the work rules the work rules
are they make feather bedding look
efficient
i mean the second avenue tunnel
for the subway in new york cost two and
a half
billion dollars per mile a similar
tunnel
in france uh using the same kind of
machine and everything
france is not known for its efficiency
you know a similar tunnel in paris
cost one-fifth as much so
so we're talking about we're talking
about
multiples of people uh
required by union by public union
contracts
it's just you know it literally doubles
triples quadruples
the cost of running the assembly system
or or whatever
so these are this is data
this is my world these are hard facts
this is these are numbers
i mean with
the system as it stands today i mean
we can't bring ross perot back from the
dead
the the type of radical reform that
you're talking about which is
effectively eradicating unions just so
we can get some work done
and educate some children i
what's the pathway and that's like my
last question
so we're going to have to go backwards
in time but that's my i i have to throw
it out there
yeah so um that's not really my last
question
history shows that change happens in big
gulps
it doesn't happen incrementally i mean
things happen in ground but not much
you know the changes that show up in
history books happen
so the last time we had a big change in
this country were the 1960s
where we had the where we had the right
excuse me
the last time we had big change when we
had the rights revolution so we woke up
to all these abuses racial
discrimination
pollution other things and we and we
changed the way we organized government
but some of the changes we made didn't
work
and uh the changes included a kind of a
micromanagement approach to regulation
including there was no such thing as
collective bargaining by public unions
before then they just slipped in
during the 1960s there were no abuses
that people were fixing
they just slipped in and so
a lot of the things that make society
not work
occurred during then we did need to
change our values about pollution and
such
but some of the other things we need to
change to give back
uh to people i think the freedom to take
responsibility the school principal the
teacher the you know
the whoever's running the mta you know
they need to be able to manage
you know their their public services so
so how do you
fix this the public unions are a big
problem because they're politically so
powerful
right and and because their contracts
have long tails
the political system can't really fix it
because they have a contract in place
right so they can't you can elect
somebody new but the somebody new
doesn't actually have the authority
to to run this so they've they've
effectively um
uh kind of corroded really worse than
that they pulled the rug out from under
democracy
we're supposed to be able to elect
people to run
government run schools run the mpa
whatever right you know and and
they don't have the authority because
these public union contracts
so um i uh
believe that the way to
fix that particular problem is to
have collective bargaining declared
unconstitutional
uh in by the supreme court and
i'm uh i've written about this uh
uh there's a part of the constitution
that's really never been applied in this
context but it's well known called the
guarantee clause
that where the federal government
guarantees a republican form of
government
um to all the states and what that means
is the history shows that
that voters retain the power to elect
people
to run the government so a state
couldn't be run by an aristocracy
or a monarchy that the voters the
the voters maintain the authority to
elect people who have the authority
to run the government that's what a
republican former government is supposed
to provide but that's been severed
because it's the unions who are
effectively in
in control that's correct and so i
so my belief and this is my idea but i'm
i'm we're developing it and you've got
leading scholars working with us and
such
uh is that is that the unions have
basically taken away the power of the
voter
with these contracts and therefore the
solution
lies not politically it's very difficult
but it lies in a constitutional
challenge
so i'm just jumping all around here
because you said constitution um
while we're at it can we address term
limits
uh you know it's interesting um term
limits they put in term limits in the
state of california
and it didn't do any good and what
happened was
people would get elected i think they
could serve two terms or something
and they immediately started sucking up
to
whatever the special interest group that
would hire them
when their terms ended so
so it actually so it actually didn't
do what was intended to do however
um you know your point about the
senators getting older and older and
older you know you will
you know you will have people born in
1930 you know sort of running the
country in 2030
um the uh is
is also correct so i i mean i look
at uh i look at pat toomey
and i'm i'm i'm borderline starting at
pat to meet fan club
uh just because he had the power
at towards the end of his term which he
promised would be his last one
uh to draw a line in congress
and refused to allow my former employer
the federal reserve
to grandfather keep alive
programs that would have effectively
allowed for
blue state unionized bailouts right
and he really didn't care about the
consequences the ramifications
he's not counting to anybody he's
leaving in 2022 he knows he's out the
door
but it's that it's that type of behavior
you say okay
how could term limits not help because
because you can actually get a few
adults in the room
who are willing to take risks right i
you know i think that's a good point i
think there's a
i think we're at a point now where where
disruption
of the political status quo
is it's just a great need
you know we can't just keep going the
same way you know they said washington's
an inch and a status quo
you know we need to change the people
the you know there actually
has been a fair amount of turnover in
the house of representatives
which uh which frankly hasn't done that
much good
um um you know so we should also
if you want to talk about the parties
you know and where the parties have gone
wrong and
possible ways of keeping the parties
honest
but but is there a way of keeping just
two
uh the way our system works now is
is the third party always always loses
and so you need something like ranked
choice voting
you know where you can get third
uh where you can get moderate selected
you know and
today the system because of the primary
system and and
such really favors
one extremist and two uh people from one
of the two parties and the person
who is the kind of might be the
compromise candidate in the middle it
would be better
never has a chance and so ranked choice
voting
um elevates that so so we could change
rank choice vote
to rank choice voting which uh a couple
of states have done i think
maine has done romaine is your perfect
example
right and uh well maine has wonderful
members i mean both senator king and
susan collins are both very moderate you
know i've met collins
i i i had my my oldest two children
read her speech about kavanaugh and all
the meetings that she had with him
on an individual basis and looking back
at his at all his rulings and
determining for herself i mean she
actually
went and did the work and i made my
children read that speech right
uh my view is that um on the parties
that uh there are some structural things
like rank choice voting but i also think
we could create um what i might call an
overlay party
and um and the overlay party
would have principles that could be
adopted by people running for either the
republic or democratic
party but it would be uh like operating
system principles
like govern for goals get rid of excess
bureaucracy
um you know you've got to make sure
people
can be accountable you know get rid of
the public union
lack of accountability
and things that allow people to run a
school or to run a hospital system in
an effective way so so get rid of this
incredible bureaucratization that's
occurred over the last 50 years in the
name of
everything you know central planning is
right so it's mainly what i write about
but you could
no one really disagrees about the need
to make schools work better to make
hospitals work better to get rid of
excessive cost
in infrastructure projects which we can
talk about
nobody disagrees with those things but
neither is not
part of the ideology of either party
and so what i'm proposing is to create
a third layer i'll call it the common
sense layer
where we're going to reboot all these
structures
that are that allow managers to actually
manage things that allow
people building infrastructure to do so
efficiently that allow
they give permits in a year rather than
10 years
that you know and all and have this
overlay
and have candidates from either party
subscribe or not to the overlay and if
they do
then they get funding from supporters
who say
i'm a republican and i also agree with
this common sense overlay
i'm a democrat but i'm going to support
this commonsense overlay and so
not unlike the progressive era when
candidates from both parties would
actually
take on things like and support things
like women's suffrage for example
this this would be um
an overlay of of what i think americans
really want
let's just make things work again
absolutely
right but it sounds like if i'm reading
in between the lines
it sounds like money is at the key
is it the core of yes and so
and so if you create a um
right now the money funnels into both
parties
and the and the funders almost
universally in my experience
or frustrated to death by the fact that
the parties nonetheless
stick with these ex whatever their
you know whatever ideology they feel
like they have to go along with right
and so what i'm suggesting is let's
funnel
the money not into the particular
candidates or parties
but into a new
practical approach to government
basically reboot reboot these
sclerotic legacy bureaucracies so that
things can work again
and that people in the community can
provide social services in their own way
that schools can be run effectively
the doctors and nurses can spend their
time looking at patients instead of
spending
two hours on desk work for every hour
with a patient
you know this kind of absurd stuff
that's going
do you know two facts
about 30 percent of the health care
dollar in america
and we pay almost twice as much as other
countries right goes to administration
that's a trillion dollars or a million
dollars productive
going to paperwork basically
um some of that's in the fee for service
and some of it's in sort of overwatch
regulatory frameworks like privacy
and very overly detailed electronic
health records
i was having um lunch with the
former president johns hopkins and uh we
were talking about this he said
a doctor had recently called him and
really frustrated he couldn't
the the electronic health record kept
getting bounced by the system
you know these are really detailed so
finally this this doctor got
a real person on the phone about why the
why the
the system kept bouncing back this this
patient
record electronic patient record and
uh the person on the phone said it keeps
bouncing back because you didn't ask the
patient
if she had ever been a smoker there was
a box you had to check
a box that was not checked yeah yeah the
box that was not checked that way you'd
ever been a smoker
and the doctor responded said well if
you'd looked at the top of the sheet
you would notice that the patient was
two years old
[Laughter]
so you have so you have these
these crazy bureaucratic systems that
are designed for completeness
but literally overwhelm
people during the day i mean so
there's this whole body of cognitive
psychology
called cognitive overload a cognitive
load theory
where the where some of the leading
people that have joined
our common good coalition because their
studies tell them
that if you give people too much detail
to comply with
you actually uh
freeze our conscious brain which should
only keep six or seven things in mind
so-called working memory
and you end up uh not being able to
access the smart part of the human brain
which is the subconscious the long-term
memory that where things
were solutions to problems or the the
right diagnosis pops up
in a way that's really not logical
but it comes out of your experience they
tell you when you're young you know you
can't let your kids sit in front of
screens too long they get sensory
overload
yes exactly it zaps their brains right
and so
what these experts basically have found
is you give people too much bureaucracy
to comply with
you make them go brain dead
and so what we've done in this society
in schools and hospitals really
everywhere
is you make people worry about things
that are secondary tertiary or just
filling out the list in ways that make
it
hard for them to roll up their sleeves
and actually solve problems use their
common sense
and i think that's a lot of the source
of the alienation why people are so
angry
you know it's the source of why we had a
tea party it's a source of
of of make america great again people
don't really articulate it and brittany
trump didn't articulate it
but but there is this sense that people
aren't allowed to be ourselves you know
and to make things happen
and that's right and it's it's but it
hasn't it wasn't done because
it's bad to regulate worker safety or to
be concerned about patient safety it's
bad
because you can't do those things
because you're overwhelmed with trying
to get
to doing those things yeah yeah you're
with thousand page rulebooks
speaking of thousand pages the tax code
right right right the tax code my
favorite uh
it's not my favorite every year my cpa
takes a little bit longer and a little
bit
the more they simplify my taxes the
longer it takes him
um
taxes
uh at best involve rough justice
you know there's no and uh and
and a tax system is something that
periodically simply has to be rebooted
just like
napoleon created a new civil code
and he he appointed four judges it only
took him five months to actually redo
all the codes of france to come up with
a proposal a simplified code these
inefficient french really know how to
get things done
well they actually have a theory of
authority so
and and and then it wasn't napoleon's
just doing it himself
the legislature in france met
over each code and debated for over a
year each one and made
and napoleon himself presided over half
of their
proceedings it was he said and it's
right his most
lasting accomplishment and that code is
still the basis or the evolution of it
of civilized law for half the world
right and
uh periodically you have to
it's called recodify you have to redo
codes to simplify so they take a life of
their own
the united states tax code is
the most obvious example of that i mean
we need
a radically radically simpler system
there's so many
freebies and special benefits built into
you know i talked about the special
interest groups boy there are special
interest groups for like
every page of the tax code oh
and and you know something we've we've
we've spoken about
in the past and it's just why do a
certain
number of americans even have to deal
with taxes
i mean until you hit a certain income
bogey why even
i mean it just seems like clearly
clearly i mean we should
it should just be so radically
simplified there should be
a general agreement on whatever the
slice should be
for for you know some income up to a
fairly big income
then get slightly more complicated when
people have their own business whatever
unavoidably
but but even so you know it could be
simplified there are
there's some really smart people who've
thought about this over the years
um you know and people disagree about
whether we should
move towards a consumption tax for
example
um and others but uh michael gratz is
somebody who's a tax professor has been
sort of a radical thinker in this regard
but
but in general you said how do we make
change
this country is overdue overdue by over
by probably two decades
for a recodification aimed
not at changing our values but making
things
work practically which is the american
character
and and we're not going to get that
recodification
until we create a new public narrative
which neither party will lead for
the special interest groups a new public
narrative
aimed at making things work again
you know a practical not an ideological
a practical narrative
and so what i'm trying to do with common
good i've been working with people like
mitch daniels whom you know
who's now the president of purdue and
bill bradley
and several think tanks the progressive
policy institute american enterprise
institute
people at brookings we're we're all
trying to come together
at this moment to
launch a series of public discussions
which i hope you'll be a part of
on the need to reboot the system
to make things work gosh
what a radical idea can i get an amen i
mean
and it and you're right though it
seems like 2016
was one of those moments and yet here we
are four years later
and congress is
more divided than it's ever been it
seems like
it seems like reconciliation is going to
be used as a weapon of mass destruction
right and that the time we get
to midterms which the republicans are
already campaigning for
aggressively they've like they've
already stopped legislating they're
finished
they're just looking at 2022. right and
democrats are just making legislation
just however they want to make it
and i speak to my friends inside the
beltway and
they're like well if you classify the
legislation as being something to
relieve
covet then you can make all kinds of
things reconciliation
i'm like well this is just going to tear
us further apart
and and i don't my biggest pet peeve
what i've written about the most
what i did burns me up especially as
somebody who lives in texas where
hundreds of thousands of oil field
workers have been displaced and now it's
a much more
efficient economic industry than it once
was
even if they go back to their old
production levels they won't have to
bring back the same number of workers
just like the steel industry back in the
70s and the 80s when there was massive
strikes in pittsburgh
and we first started importing steel and
all of a sudden
what was left of the domestic industry
was a very streamlined
version of its prior self but there are
there tons of workers out there
who could easily be picked up and put
into positions where they could quickly
i mean if you're if you're the state of
texas manages to get its highways built
pretty quickly
and they work with private companies and
we've got great roads
so we know that there are ways to get
these and we know that the workers are
there
and scattered throughout the country and
yet
i get the sneaking sensation that we're
gonna pass three four trillion dollars
of infrastructure spending
and not do anything right well that's
what happened you know the 800 billion
dollars it was the stimulus
seemed like a lot of money at the time
uh back in 2009.
you have to be a former central banker
yeah it was uh
the 800 billion dollars a lot of that
was aimed at infrastructure remember
i mean it was supposed to be spent it's
gonna be great investment such
five years later the obama
administration did a report
uh showing where the money had been
spent turned out 3.6
had been spent on transportation
infrastructure the reason
because of the obama said there's no
such thing as a shovel ready project
and so instead of changing it which is
what fbi fdr did
when he was confronted with bureaucratic
roadblocks he just blew through them
um obama just accepted it
and um so i've written a lot about this
and studied it uh the delays in
permitting
because of these kind of endless red
tape cycles where you have three four
thousand page environmental impact
statements
overturning every pebble i did a
report on the project to raise the
roadway of the bayonne bridge
in order to allow post-panamax ships to
go into newark harbor
and some really brilliant
practical public employee had figured
out that you didn't have to build a new
bridge you'd have to tear down the old
bridge and have to build a tunnel
you could just raise the roadway within
the existing 80 year old arch it was
going to save
75 of the cost and have no environmental
impact it was using the same foundation
right right
it took them five years and a 20 000
page environmental assessment
to get approval to do a project that had
no environmental impact
including required studies of all the
historic buildings within a two-mile
radius even though the project was not
affecting
any buildings at all i mean it was just
like this this law
has kind of you know we're all choking
on this law
and something similar is going to happen
with this infrastructure plan
unless they change the rules now
in the 2016 election both hillary and
trump
cited my report which is called two
years not 10 years right
uh you know on this and then when trump
got elected
he tried and did
make some of the changes that i
suggested
but i remember the public private
partner there was a lot of talk about it
yeah exactly and
but the problem is ultimately the
solution
to that and the solution to many
of the problems in the regulatory state
is that you've got to give people the
authority to use your common sense so
an official like the head of the council
of environmental quality
has to have the authority to say oh
you're just raising the roadway
of the bridge of existing foundations
give me 50 pages of construction impacts
no one has that authority i need one
traffic study
yeah exactly and so and so that doesn't
mean they can do whatever they want they
still have to comply with the general
goal
set forth and statutes of doing of
studying
important environmental impacts but that
case requires a judgment
that well there's really no important
environmental impact so just do a little
a little review on how it's going to
affect the neighbors and that's it
but no one has that authority and we
need to change
the laws to give people
the authority to use their common sense
and
again neither party we talk about the
parties not doing it and using
reconciliation
all these real ways neither party has
the idea
of simplifying these structures so that
people can use their common sense again
that's why we have to create an outside
force
you know not unlike the tea party but
it's not tear down government
it's actually make it work and let's
have a way of holding
officials accountable when it doesn't
you know that's sort of the formula for
life right and it ought to be the
formula for government as well
you know it when when you were
describing napoleon
and his being at the helm and getting
things done
and periodically doing reviews
china kept coming into mind right now
china has
30 airports 30 that are under some stage
of construction
and or modernization they've got
high-speed railways
i mean i hate to say that china's the
example but
every five years or so they come
together they reassess
and they say are we sticking to our
long-term goals if not let's change the
rules and move on
right so so let's so you don't have to
be a totalitarian state to make things
work
america used to make things work they
built the erie canal
then you know all sorts they built the
interstate highway system the interstate
highway bill
1956 was 29 pages long
10 years later they built 21 000 miles
of road
today the last transportation bill was
close to a thousand pages and it would
take 10 years just to go through the
review process
so so something has happened in america
that's fundamentally dysfunctional that
neither party
is talking about and that's something is
that no one is given
the margin of authority needed to take
responsibility to build the road to how
the contractors up
and to be accountable for it we've
created we've tried to create this
self-enclosed
bureaucratic system where all people do
is follow rules all day long
and well let's say the truism
nothing in the history of mankind
ever got accomplished because someone
followed a rule
that's what's happening how that rules
are there to prevent bad things from
happening i'm not against
you know i'll rule but if you want
something to happen you want to have a
classroom be successful that requires
the energy and willpower and love
and skill of the teacher you you know
you want to
run an effective
infrastructure building program that
requires a contractor who's
working hard and under pressure and you
know to
has to produce has a bottom line produce
at the price you know and all of that
um and and we have lost
that idea and so um
so that's why i think we need to to
build a new political movement that's
not ideological but this
that's it's about empowering humans
both to do and to judge each other about
how we're doing
so
when you think about kind of the near
term
and
the fact that a good portion of the
country feels like its voice was never
heard
and this whole idea of a middle ground
and we're in a world of social media
right
i mean how how does somebody how do
i help to
get the word out to multiple generations
that that this is how simple it could be
right i mean how do you communicate the
message
in real time in the world we live in
when
it's so much easier to spread
disinformation right
well what we're doing is we're having
this conversation so that's important
um you know i think we do need to
uh uh make what i'm talking about into a
thing
you know we need to have the the slogan
and have that be we have seven governing
principles at commongood.org
the first one is govern for goals
the last one is restore the moral the
seventh restore the moral basis of
public choices
you know we need to argue about things
it's right and wrong it is wrong
to spend two and a half million dollars
billion dollars for a mile
of subway in new york when it could cost
one-fifth that that's
wrong that's two billion dollars out of
taxpayers pockets is two billion dollars
that could be spent educating
underprivileged i mean
it's the every public dollar involves a
moral choice
and if we're wasting doll if we know
that we're wasting dollars we're acting
immorally and we have to
argue it on that basis you can't argue
it it's just no that's inefficient
the same with climate change i'm
concerned about climate change so let's
let's deal with it but don't argue about
it is can you prove
that houston's going to be flooded in 20
years no i can't afford that
but but you know let's argue about as a
fellow stewardship
we have obligations moral obligations of
stewards to act responsibly for future
generations just since
our parents built the interstate highway
system for us or whatever we need to
build a system that works
you know for for for our children and
grandchildren
and we don't have that we're not arguing
these things in moral terms anymore
we're arguing them in ideological terms
with social media
you know there's this americans there's
this whole narrative about how
the last election proved that americans
are all divided and stuff i don't buy
that
they're divided by social media they're
divided by all these abstractions but
they're not really divided about what
they want
there was this book written a couple
years ago by
james fallows and deborah fallows called
our towns
and jim i know a little bit uh is a
is a is a private pilot he has a little
single engine plane so they flew around
the country
for a couple of years and would spend
weeks in different towns and stuff and
describe
what was going on in those towns and how
people felt and what they were doing
civically and one of the towns they
visited was dodge city kansas
and i think it's kansas and in dodge
city you know famous dodge city but
voted 76 for trump you know they're you
know they're
completely conservative they had
recently
passed an 85 million dollar bond
for a local school
of which 85 of the students
were children of of migrant workers
and immigrants they had done all these
projects
not for
you know not to help the the white
people who had been there for years
right who were all voting for trump but
to help the people who were not like
them
and and the point of the story is that
and there are lots of studies that back
this up is that most
people want to be good they want to do
what's right they want to do what's
needed
and then dodge city an incredibly
conservative town
what was needed was to help the
underprivileged so these people
open their pocketbooks to do that and
and so i you know i just don't buy the
narrative
that that people are divided they don't
have
if you give people back a measure of
authority
to provide social services their own way
they'll take ownership
things will work better they'll start
helping those underprivileged children
if you make it all be your bureaucratic
rules coming from
on high and you make it hard for the
church or synagogue to
to provide programs in their basement
because there's a little religion
attached to it if you
you know if you if all the if all the
rules get in the way
then you drive people out but if you do
my father was a preacher
if you i'm getting that yeah yeah if you
if if you let people
have the chance to help other people in
their community
they will and it will not only be good
for the people who need help it'll be
really
good for the people who are doing the
helping i mean when you talk about
community there was this massive ice
storm snow storm that hit
texas and
it woke it it awakened
a sense of community right that
i mean i had i had my mother my best
friend's mother my best friend her two
kids
her dog i mean it was it was a little
cozy in there
but i was one of i was one of thousands
of people
i mean we looked around us there was
genuine tragedy
there were people in 39 degree homes
and you know this was bureaucracy gone
bad
this is something that could have been
prevented
and yet what came out of this
was people having it's kind of like
what's come out of covid
i mean a sense of family has emerged
from covet
in a lot of parts of the country because
you know you're either going to knock
off one of your children
or get used to having them all under the
same roof again
and eventually you know you're riding
around your neighborhood
on sunday afternoon and you're one of
many families of five and six people
riding around their neighborhoods on
sunday afternoon getting fresh air and
so we covet gave us family
but tragedy seemed to give
texas community and it just seems like
that's so
missing in the fabric yeah i i i think
re-empowering community i've been
um is it
it would just be so good for for
american culture
uh there's so many things that need to
happen
on a on a community level starting with
helping underprivileged children
and there's i have a uh i have a friend
years ago we were having he was very
successful wall street
executive and
we were having lunch in 35 years
and we're talking about economic things
he said you know ultimately
an economy is what you value
i never really thought about that and um
so for example if a society values
creating big stone heads then you'll
have an island culture where all they
did was create big stone heads until
they went
right you know until they went extinct
basically because
big stone heads weren't that you know
didn't didn't put food on people's
tables
but um he said what do we value
as a society well we you know we're past
the point
happily in this country mainly of food
you know so but we're but there's still
a lot of people on the edge and
so we need to deal with that but
going back to the beginning of
discussion making it easier for women to
work and
you know and other things
but we can also value things
that we haven't put priorities on
including
caring for children especially caring
for underprivileged children
local cultural activities you know the
the band in the gazebo you know they
used to have a hundred years ago or
whatever
um and it and a sense of kind of local
pride in a
uh you know of helping each other and
community and there used to be the town
green
exactly and and so
you read jim and debbie fallow's book
and you get a
sense that that instinct still exists
but the systems aren't designed to make
it easy for people to do that
and so uh you know in a world
where you had much simpler regulatory
codes
where you had oversight not for specific
compliance whether you have a material
safety data sheet for the joy
dishwashing liquid in your
in your you know business or all these
young idiocies of modern bureaucracy
or check the box whether you were asked
the patient whether they were a smoker
or not
smoker's three years old yeah yeah you
know all these idiocy
where you have a sense that that
regulatory goals are about
protecting um uh
outer boundaries and you let people
within those boundaries
do things in their own way so it's a
it's a simpler goal oriented regulatory
autonomy within some simple guardrails
yes exactly and so if you created a
framework like that
that re-empowers people to do things in
their own way
oh my god it would just be
it would you know communities could
learn from each other they i mean
it would just be wonderful for our
self-respect and i think the alienation
that
that has driven a lot of the kind of
political craziness and extremism
would disappear it was just vaporized
because people would wake up in the
morning knowing they can make a
difference
in their own community
we need to bring back community banks
that that's that's a thought that came
to mind
by the way because that's what helps
communities grow
i mean i i learned a few weeks ago
conducting another interview
that the majority of germans exporters
are very small businesses that have a
very robust
network of small not-for-profit
community banks
that make sure that they take care of
their given radius and make sure that
their economies flourish
and i said well what a radical idea i
just
well you know banking you're a banking
expert
banking traditional banking was based on
reputation and uh you know and
it wasn't it wasn't hardline data
you know stuff i mean you looked at
whether the company had a chance to see
it or not but you knew
you the community banker knew the people
involved and had a sense of
whether they would you know make it
right no or not i mean i started a firm
you know in the early 80s so a long time
ago and i needed to
borrow uh close to a million dollars to
to you know build out the office and all
that kind of stuff
and uh and i went to a banker i knew
and i didn't have i didn't
i didn't you know they they gave us the
loan because
they thought that i was a serious
substantial person
and that i would figure out a way to
make it simple they said he's good for
the money
and that was yeah and they knew it
though because they were part of
the community that you were part of
right um
so we're coming up on the 100 year
anniversary of
gennaro di martino landing
at ellis island a great great historic
event
absolutely i mean he went on to live the
american dream i mean he
he was in the service in the 40s he was
two years old when he came
a non-smoker um but he came over and
ended up uh working and being trained as
a mechanic in great britain during world
war ii
he came back to east haven
where he had settled and he ended up
with two dimartino sunocos on either
side of i-95
and i'm a third-generation gear head
as a result but he was the american
dream
and i feel like that american dream has
somehow been lost on us where does
immigration
belong yeah it's interesting you know
uh immigrants are doing incredibly well
it's americans that aren't doing so well
you know you you you look at uh
communities
um uh
you know not just the silicon valley or
places where you have these obvious
geniuses come in and they you know
create
google or they run microsoft right you
know or
whatever but um
uh but you look at many communities and
you find
uh that the people who are who become
the civic leaders are
immigrants there's uh one of the stories
in the phallus book is a
town called columbus mississippi where
one of the leading protagonists that is
is indian he's an indian extraction i
mean it's a
in columbus mississippi i mean this is
you know how does this compute
and um
it's uh eastern europeans and upstate
new york
there are lots of success stories of
immigrants
and and why is that well
it's the same as your was it this your
grandfather
uh it's the same as your grandfather you
know people come in and they say
i'm allowed to do what i can do
and so they don't let themselves be held
back
by the the rules or the prejudice or
anything else
you know they they go and do and they do
what it takes
and instead we have a narrative
this entitlement narrative just drives
me nuts
i mean people say well i'm being held
back
well yes yes and every immigrant every
immigrant
uh has been held back and there is in in
and we certainly want to minimize or get
rid of if we could
discrimination and such but
people succeed and immigrants succeed
in spite of that and they succeed the
way all people succeed
which is by pleasing the people
around them they make a product or
provide a service
that works and notwithstanding the fact
that maybe some people are against them
they continue to pro do the work
that people need or want and guess what
that
generally leads to success i mean
we're in the room with sam who's not on
camera right now but sam came over from
from columbia to attend high school in
the united states
alone because he knew that where he was
there were barriers
right and success story in the making
i was in the back of a i was on my way
to an airport recently stuck in traffic
and
i got in got into a chat with the guy
the lyft
driver take me to the airport and it was
around the time of the election and he
said
what are you people fighting with each
other for
i came from i can't remember what
country you came for he said i came from
this country and
the opportunities that i have here
there's just nothing to complain about
i'm on my way to success and
you're killing each other right right
and they have this vision of the our
country that's better than our vision of
our country yeah yeah and completely and
so there's a
you know there's a sense of modern
america that's
just like a you know sort of like a rich
family with too much money that's
quarreling over the money instead of
appreciating you know sort of
you know what they have again that's a
reason why
you know i think if you if if we could
create a new narrative
of of human empowerment and
responsibility
and accountability the old narrative
and and begin to have proposals
about how to make it where okay how can
we start building infrastructure in a
year this is what the permitting fund
how do we avoid waste in feather bedding
and infrastructure you know these are
the laws we need to get rid of
how do we how do we engage
local community energy to help the
underprivileged
here's how we need to frame here's the
framework we need that allows people to
actually take ownership
rather than having big brother tell them
how to provide the services
if we start coming up with these
proposals it's actually not that hard to
do
it's it's actually easy to create
simple laws that are implemented by
humans taking responsibility that's easy
we're creating those laws i could do it
looks like
napoleon appointed four judges um the
main guy was in portalis
to do it i would love the job
give me three other people and we'll
we'll we'll just blow through every
every every
area we'll create simplified codes and
we can do it within a year
and those codes they won't change any
public goals we're not we're not for
unsafe workplaces or whatever
we give people back would be
goal-oriented
principles oriented give back people
back the freedom
to do things in their own way and we
could you would see
a surge of energy not just rebuilding
infrastructure and stuff that would
happen
but of local energy that would be
that would be in history books because
people are frustrated to death
by this system and so they they
they get lost in this kind of narrative
this polarized narrative
so um i'm going to wrap up with a
question that you might or might not be
able
to answer and you're a self-identified
lawyer
so you can't take that yeah i can't take
it back
we are a nation of checks and balances
that sometimes uses
checks and balances as a shield
is there a role that the judiciary can
play
i always my gallows humor was that
you're finally going to get the illinois
judiciary to work when some judge
doesn't get the ambulance to show up on
time
because he keeps voting the pensions
rights in one generation
is there a role that the supreme court
can play such that the people could have
a voice in in designing a new system
or is that just too far-fetched um no
it's not too far-fetched i mean
the ultimate well the ultimate power
actually does come with the people
but tocqueville said there's amazing
power in the point of view of people so
ultimately the name of the game here is
for you and i
to create a new narrative get a lot of
americans sign on to it
turn it into a political action
committee support candidates from either
parties that this new
human empowerment narrative so that's
the ultimate goal
but yes the supreme court could do some
amazing things they could
declare for the recent stated public
union collective bargaining
unconstitutional
they could this is really important they
could direct
the trial courts
to dismiss
any claims that would undermine the
freedoms of people not in the courtroom
so if somebody brings a lawsuit because
their kid fell off a see-saw
and hurt their head
you can't let that claim go to jury
whatever the jury does theories are
generally sensible
because what will happen is people will
be at risk for see-saw so all those sea
salts will get ripped out
and that's what's happened basically in
america there are no seats out there
the um
what the judge ought to say is i want to
hear
expert testimony of whether seesaws are
for kids of a certain age a reasonable
risk because it teaches them how to
cooperate and all that kind of stuff
um that is fun it gets them outdoors and
exercise
and if it is a reasonable risk that i'm
going to make a ruling as a matter of
law
about whether the claim should be
allowed because if i allow the lawsuit
to go to the jury
all the seesaws will be ripped out
because no one's going to want to pay
the risk
so we need to understand that what
people can sue for
establishes the boundaries of everyone
else's freedom
and that's an idea that's been lost in
our society
it hasn't been lost in the uk which is
also a common law country which has had
a bunch of rulings
exactly on that point i've met with and
talked with and did forums with the
law lords on this anyone
and and the supreme court if it did that
and it got rid of the public unions that
would enormously liber both those things
would enormously liberate people
and back to my favorite pet peeve of the
term limit i mean that's that that is
that is an avenue that could be
absolutely termed term limits ranked
choice voting there are structural
changes
that would be really good particularly
maybe term limits
um you know in
in the senate and then um you could
um you could revisit it
again in 20 or 30 years i mean my view
about electoral rules
is that they always need to change in
order for
not to have some game slip in you know
you
you need to constantly kind of
disrespect we just learned that in this
in this last election
right right so all those things are good
um
one last one i lied i have one last one
uh
what did kovat teach us about government
in america
um it it taught us that
when you have immediate needs like the
need to trace people coming over
a year ago you can't
require the public health officials to
get
approval first from washington took them
a month to start acting i mean it was
really
simple there was one guy one public
health researcher in seattle
who sent an emergency application to
start
trying to trace people and it got
bounced
because he hadn't submitted it in hard
copy he'd only submitted it on email
i mean you know what is the mindset of
these people
so so it taught us that it taught that
if you unleash the power of private
initiative
like with creating the vaccines amazing
things can happen i mean
this was a global phenomenon right these
were thousands and thousands and
thousands of scientists
just with open lines of communication
right and it also
taught that if you want to vaccinate
a population you need to have
a business leader maybe like somebody
who ran factories in world war ii or
something
you need to have someone who actually
knows how to organize
action and the states were just
floundering all over the place you know
it's just been
as as we know where they've gradually
gotten their act together
but months later than it should have so
so there were places where like with the
creation of a vaccine
and which occurred but with the
distribution which did not occur
where where we really need to put people
in charge
you know give people a responsibility of
doing it
and and every time the bureaucracy got
involved whether it was with
stopping the coveted initially or
creating the first test or or doing the
vaccine whatever the bureaucracy gets
involved in dictating how to do things
it fails if it goes back to the thing
people things don't good things don't
happen because people will follow rules
good things happen because somebody
rolls up their sleeves and make it
happen
and so uh kovid
has thought that um
it's given us that lesson in on several
levels
well uh from the bottom of my heart i
hope that
that you can continue to spread the
common good with this latest
example that's going to be very fresh in
people's minds
for a long time it was great to be with
you and i you know i think there's a
great opportunity here
the american people are dying to be you
know to to
be able to take responsibility again
let's create
oh i'm framework to let it happen i
you've got my voice i'm i'm all on board
i'm looking forward
grace again great to be with you same
here thank you
i hope that you are as electrified as i
am
i'm telling you i had to get on an
airplane to come and do this in person
this was not a zoom moment for me
uh if you enjoyed what i have to say if
you want to get behind the movement if
you want to find your voice
as a moderate american join me go to
commongood.org
and study more reach out to me
individually i'll send you everything
i've ever written on infrastructure
it's gonna happen one person at a time
and in the event that you're new to down
the middle i
invite you to go to the last time i got
on an airplane for my very first
interview with jeffrey gun like and then
watch every episode since
because it is my aim financial literacy
bringing about more common good that's
what we're all about and if you haven't
subscribed
please do so and i look forward to the
next time
i get to visit with you at down the
middle thank you